on va parler des profs des cylindres est
ce qu'on a vu un gâteau proulx faire les
pros d'ici là je vais gagner ou pas
agathe font pas du tout les imaginait
alors on est obligé de revoir les images
de ce qu'on voit en quoi ça vous dérange
aoued vous êtes magnifique sur l'essai
n'est pas interdit de maintenance a fait
preuve c'est un fait justement on va en
parler avec olivier avec des fins
briques pourquoi cette épreuve est
interdite regard pour avancer
[Musique]
mettront-ils elle lui fait divinement
même écart le leinster n'est pas
[Applaudissements]
alors honteuses comme ça tu es c'est
très beau et magnifique sur le scénario
et cette coiffure là ce petit carré
plongeant la libération du style un
merci alors l'idée pourquoi ils ont
enlevé les portes du final très
sincèrement la version qui m'a été
donnée
on peut toujours nous servir la soupe
qu'on veut c'est que cet endroit qui
étaient les cylindres comme l'autre
pièce qui était consacrée au jard était
une des pins des espaces les plus grands
et pour cette saison nous avons eu nous
avons créé la banque
il vous le verrez état décors absolument
hallucinant qui demandait beaucoup de
mètres carrés est le seul espace qui
représentait le mètre carré dont on
avait besoin c'était sur les six là ça
coince
est-ce que ça a coïncidé actuellement ça
a aidé à retirer s'était preuve qu'ils
pouvaient susciter parfois quelques
émotions la parole des femmes c'est
autre chose mais moi je sais que
fondamentalement la production est parti
sur l'arrêt des six lames d'abord et
avant tout par rapport à fait de trouver
de l'espace c'était pas du tout plaindre
mais seulement 13 % de réussite qu'il
sous entend qu'une nouvelle épreuve
gagner davantage en 2012 donc ça se
compte sur les toits les doigts de la
main les personnes qui ont essayé en
2012 c'est la seule épreuve que j'ai
réussi à fort boyard dans sport il s'est
peut-être à cause de ça que le père
fouras m'a appelé pour incarner après
enfin rejoindre l'équipe mais c'est la
seule épreuve des souvenirs pleins
oh là là là là là oui qu'est ce que vous
voulez olivier est charmant mais vous
nous faites une langue de bois terrible
non juré en mai les sinon il aurait vu
je te bouges pas ces soirées celle ci
lui ont dit en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit moi je pense que l'époque a
changé et que c'était preuve n'avait
plus lieu d'être quand on voit
sincèrement les marges grignard
mais les magnifiques des femmes ne
tolère plus la balle